you
ladies and gentlemen good morning the
Norwegian Nobel Committee has decided
that the Nobel Peace Prize for 2012 is
to be awarded to the European Union the
Union and its foreigners have over six
decades contributed to the advancement
of peace and reconciliation democracy
and human rights in Europe in interwar
years the Norwegian Nobel Committee made
several awards two persons were seeking
- who were seeking reconciliation
between Germany and France since 1945
that reconciliation has become a reality
the dreadful suffering in world war two
demonstrated the need for a new Europe
over a 70 year period
Germany and France had fought three wars
today war between Germany and France had
is unthinkable
this shows how through well-aimed
efforts and by building a mutual
confidence historic and miss can become
close partners in the 1980s Greece Spain
and Portugal joined the European Union
the introduction of democracy was a
condition for their membership the fall
of the Berlin Wall
made even membership possible for
several Central and Eastern European
countries thereby opening a new era in
European history the deviation between
East and West has to a large extent been
brought to an end democracy has been
strengthened many ethnic based national
conflicts have been settled the
admission of Croatia as a member next
year
the opening of membership negotiations
with Montenegro and the granting of
candidate status disturbia all
strengthens the process of
reconciliation in the Balkans in the
past decade the possibility of EU
membership for turkey has always also
advanced democracy and human rights in
that country the European Union is
currently undergoing grave economic
difficulties and considerable social
unrest the Norwegian Nobel Committee
wishes to focus on what it sees as the
EU s most important result the
successful struggle for peace and
reconciliation and for democracy and
human rights the stabilizing part played
by the European Union has helped to
transform most of Europe from a
continent of war to a continent of peace
the work of the European Union
represents fraternity between nations
and amounts to a form of the peace
congresses to which Alfred Nobel refers
at criteria for the Peace Prize in his
1895 will